hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
is John Humphrey over here alright
alright
facts over at patreon one of our patreon
reward tiers is whatever video you
request whether it be a discussion or a
review or a full-on movie to be produced
by Hollywood we will definitely put it
into production and it will see the
light of day
Kent McKnight a good buddy of ours over
at patreon from Australia Australia
Australia Australia Australia you gotta
you gotta practice
it's a hard-ass never guy remember if I
look up how to do it I can learn spider
on the ceiling spider on the ceiling
spider on the ceiling okay
my sounds become always a choice spoiler
on this wing
spider spider you gotta like I'm trying
to figure out where in your mouth and
throat this all goes spider screw this
we're Rogers finest ceilings we
requested cheese Kent that's a big old
camera Boing Jake hey I have a bed frame
just like that whoa it's a big spider
Oh
[Music]
that's worse well you can tell him that
I'm going straight to the top I'm not
kidding I know her just get the
newspaper you have no idea what you okay
it's messy and I am going to suck the
life right out of him
Oh God
the lair is the catcher oh no not in the
closet
[Laughter]
took a different animal
that was a possum catcher wasn't it
Daniel
[Music]
Wow you know her she is really pretty
she's super cool and talented is she is
actually she's like actress writer her
music is really cool like she does all
sorts of stuff
well this give her a message for me yes
so Greg is in love with this is exactly
what I what I imagine life in Australia
being like on most days I see like a
nickel sized spider on the ceiling here
and I'm like oh there yeah I'm just like
yeah it's the size of a small dog yeah
yeah why wouldn't that be on the
ceilings now you know or hiding behind a
clock or whatever I really loved the way
that sketch was executed because it was
done in such a subtle way it's just a
simple plant of the spider only moves
one tire yeah chilling this ridiculous
concept of like the fear of when it
spiders on the symbol what if it's a
really big fear and the guy just
responds kind of normally in a way of
hiding it like some people might hide
from just a regular spider yeah then I
love when the girl comes through and she
Camilla and she's that really like
engaging in it it's such a weird and
subtle but funny a sketch I love what
she comes out and she's like kill me
[Applause]
there's something I find really amusing
about about sketches where the crux of
the joke is that nobody believes that
this thing is truly as terrifying you
know be or as big of a deal as we think
it'll be you keep expecting something to
subvert the expectations but really it
just is that bad yeah you know or it
isn't that intense or that freaky or
whatever so yeah just the whole joke of
like no no no no it really is a gigantic
yeah I thought it was done in a way
where it could have been more physical
but they went a different route where it
was more than just the reactions and the
humour and the subtlety of the music you
yeah that made it so much funnier it's
kind of got a dry sense of humor about
this outlandish idea yeah yeah it's made
it all the better
I feel like the typical route would have
been to make it super outlandish but it
was really the actors and the music cues
and the direction of it that really just
enhances I love the subtlety
yes great sketch
thanks Kent appreciate you sending that
over and thanks kamila
you have my number now that my
girlfriend would be so okay with you
calling me on oh you know maybe we can
collapse sometime or something yeah yeah
I won't I want to [ __ ] my pants it's an
odd reaction that's what happens I meet
hot girls why don't go out so I'm
filling YouTube videos I don't blame if
that was the reaction I scrap to the
real rejects that notification bell
what's your favorite endangered species
comment below